[Music]
in fake Asian news fake gas agents Oh
Simon buy your girl is from Brooklyn
Matt oh sorry yeah girl Liz or Brooklyn
met ramsey my dude is opening a
self-proclaimed authentic Asian
restaurant Gordon Ramsay's so [ __ ]
young when it comes to Asian job can I
get says real quick I love Gordon Ramsay
right don't fast dude you be careful
problem with this though is that every
time he [ __ ] touches Mexican and
Asian food he [ __ ] trashes it it's
bad
what does he do to it did you see that
video where he got roasted by the Thai
okay but I saw a video where he the
title of it was the ultimate taco right
yeah and it was he just took a [ __ ]
strip loin steak he cooked it and he
just put like miso over it and he put
like a Mexican slaw into a premade
tortilla and he says the ultimate talk
my bro just [ __ ] just stick to your
[ __ ] dude or at least I have somebody
teach you how to make this stuff don't
just [ __ ] put that garbage on it was
anything like the [ __ ] pie you baked
ah then I believe what I didn't make you
got so we were making I think this
rethinks Thanksgiving we had pizzas in
the oven and then he thought it'd be a
good idea to whatever store-bought pie
he had to put it in the oven with the
pizzas and then that [ __ ] oh and he put
it in the rack too so that she just fell
apart but he didn't even put a tray on
it it was just on the rack itself and
then it just started didn't save the
portray on it oh [ __ ] man David I don't
have this like the thing where you're
born and you can cook some
[ __ ] survivor I do understand if I
believe you can't make Tucker I don't
want to try anything Steve mix that's
not true I just made a carrot cake with
Boz she said it's the great Gary she's
ever had in her life and she's had a
bunch of it's a bunch of vegan [ __ ] - no
no I can vouch for vegan [ __ ] cuz I used
to eat that forever and after a while
your taste buds get kind of a little
wonky I needed this because this is my
only solar cream cooking we should cook
of it we should baking's not cooking
Steve you just make scrambled eggs and
all you do you you turn on the [ __ ]
stove right and you throw an egg onto it
no it doesn't matter what I do because I
covered in hot sauce anyway that's
what's beautiful about my cooking good
just like the texture of the hot sauce
on it the texture I mean ya can't taste
like [ __ ] cartilage or anything like
a big texture wise I can't be like a
cartilage bomb anyway at Gordon Ramsay
announced that he's opening a restaurant
called lucky cat in London Asian food
but the main chef that's behind the
thing is this guy oh no behind a white
guy yeah is he - he looks mixed um he
does look mix but I don't believe here
white dudes that travelled over to Asia
and did all that [ __ ] then
his name is Ben or would that's why
because there is that white chef I
forgot his name the Thai restaurant well
he's in Japan and like oh you mean that
Jewish guy that did barani get back to
New York I think an orchid I mean it was
good
yes him I haven't tried it but it's
mostly yeah I use like a very a
variation of what he does for his ramen
and it tasted good yeah yeah so a lot of
people are like um i like you corn
ramsey but how are you gonna open up an
authentic Asian restaurant without an
Asian chef so we were like come on no do
you need to have a techniques it's like
I don't understand you could have a
shitty Asian chef - holding
to the fact that it was an authentic
Asian because he put the word authentic
in it
Wow you know if you would they want to
see a whole little Asian grandma there
or something like that
what does she makes bad food that's my
whole thing so that's a shitty authentic
Asian photo I see yeah at least it's
authentic even though it's genius but
according to the rent Ramsay's
restaurant group the restaurant will be
a late night lounge taking cues from the
drinking dens of 1930s 30s Tokyo and the
Far East
and then it also said I think the word
tradition and like keeping things the
way they are is tied with the word
authentic yeah so it's not so much that
he's white but then you think that he's
gonna new age the food but if it's
actually authentic then it's like ha ha
joke's on you [ __ ] yeah yeah
because then yeah is it a specific Asian
food
it sounds like Japanese izakaya food
well 1930s Tokyo in the Far East yeah I
mean if it's a chi oh yeah it sounds
like that because I kind of feel like
it's gonna be one of those and all of a
sudden it's gonna have like Japanese or
not that's not even the color of pad
thai what was that wow you look crazy
yeah it's interesting cuz like like pad
thai or orange though yeah well if you
got it depends on where you go back to
the renewed also that orange color that
you get from pad thai is actually
picture is from ketchup yeah which is an
American thing right so it should be
brown like that because from
tastehh Oh [ __ ] hey no cuz I know I
called it up tonight's it looks like the
[ __ ] I guess Pad Thai do you yeah dude
like I get from the [ __ ] most
highest-rated one and it's like this
little type and I bet they use ketchup
but this type family runs it they're
pretty pissed while you're there when
you order they don't like you and then
who as you as you pay he takes forever
cuz he really hates credit cards it's
pretty dope but I bet it's don't say you
have to be Asian to have an authentic
restaurant because I was in Australia
and we just walked into this Thai
restaurant right and then the owner came
up to us it was this white guy right and
the food's [ __ ] amazing and we were
like how the [ __ ] do you have such
authentic ass [ __ ] like where did you
you know find the cooks and all that
stuff and they're like well my wife is
Cambodian and I was like oh there we go
and he visits Cambodia Thailand all the
time and then they they make friends
with the chefs there and they're like
you wanna work visa and come to
Australia and then they curate all that
[ __ ] and it's like yeah you could have
[ __ ] super authentic stuff but here's
a funny part right the cooks are from
Thailand they are from Thailand but
here's the funny part because but
because the owner is white and he's the
face of it they don't see the cooks
right all the white customers say this
isn't really she's like [ __ ] he's like
every single time like well the Asian
customers come in they're like oh thank
you so much for making something so like
real and not mainstream right and then
the white customers come in and they're
like I've had real Thai food in Thailand
and this is not real Thai food I was in
k-town for an AfriNIC his birthday with
my friend Vee who's from Vietnam like
vog Vietnam not like she stayed at a
resort in via she [ __ ] was in Vietnam
right and her dad was like part of like
a brainwashing camp like while she was
growing up she didn't see him for seven
years like it was like that and they
escaped and and she we went to this far
place and she was and it was like a
little family-run family-owned they're
like this is the best fall here and all
this [ __ ] and she's like this [ __ ] sucks
ass okay help us stop cuz it's
Kurian fuh it's not Vietnamese it was
Vietnamese that's what she was so pissed
oh so it's all [ __ ] it's all
[ __ ] everyone get out but it tastes
substantially different because it's
made for like it tastes more like Korean
food so like they they definitely tweak
that [ __ ] for the clientele and the
reason why I don't like when people say
authentic not in this kind of case is it
what the [ __ ] is authentic me right you
know what I mean I think like food too
it's just if you like it you [ __ ]
like it do it does it taste good that's
like American food right
like nobody's like authentic American
food yeah it's like you go to a burger
place or you go to another burger place
two disparate places better than this
burger place nobody's like well it's got
to be a guy [ __ ] white that white guy
of running flipping the burgers himself
that's where it gets weird super race is
that you have to be a certain race of
that food like you have to be that to
make it right that's the [ __ ]
stupidest [ __ ] they all have two hands
two feet
they have eyeballs they can taste things
it's the same [ __ ] thing no matter
who you are yeah you're telling me like
like if you see a Mexican sushi chef
right you're like that's not real sushi
because I've actually had really [ __ ]
good sushi from a Mexican sushi chef
right I mean they can all go and travel
and study and like like you learn all
the traditions you know like who the
[ __ ] cares but when they see this
picture they go how are you gonna do
that Gordon Ramsay like he's not he's
not Asian you can't make it authentic if
he's not Asian it's like a [ __ ] food
for it's the lowest IQ way of responding
there's no like you yeah sure I mean my
immediate stupid reaction is I see the
the storefront of this and I go this
sucks
oh yeah I mean that's what Ivan Orkin
was talking about too late and I love
Ivan Orkin because of how like crass he
is at the end he goes well you know
people come in and they tell me this
isn't real robbing egos want you [ __ ]
go to Japan and live there and learn the
language and marry a Japanese woman and
open up one of the most successful
[ __ ] Russians how's it depend and
then you come [ __ ] talk to me yeah
yeah when it's never usually the people
of that culture because once they put
that in their mouth and they're like oh
[ __ ] I respect this cuz it's Bob yeah
it's usually the people that aren't even
like they've traveled there once and
that they're like you're not [ __ ] the
real deal yeah they're trying to tell
the person like that's not really often
it's just so weird too because like my
thing is just like I said you like the
food if it tastes good then just leave
it at that and
I think with his problem mrs. here he
has like a thing of just kind of [ __ ]
up ethnic food that where it doesn't
taste good what kind of style is normal
food what's up what kind of style is go
squirt and Ramsay usually make expensive
I think he I think he like motion ish
yeah but mostly mostly most chefs they
always do like French and contemporary
food so I think that's where he starts
but he does everything in anything right
so he has his burger joint was sucked
yes multiple restaurants in Vegas that
all are yeah yeah and either namesake to
he just slaps his name on to and then
the food comes out it's really what it
is yeah you know with this to when you
when you say authentic when I hear
authentication I want it to be
affordable and good that's what I think
oh yeah sure when I think of authentic
Asian I think cockroach and I want to
see a [ __ ] thumb in my soup dude and
I want you to bring it out I want to
lick it and then put it into my kimono
cut see but see I view that as american
diner food and a nice hair in any way oh
that's authentic American when you I
think what's gonna happen is that
they're they're gonna expect it to taste
really good and it's gonna taste decent
but it's gonna be [ __ ] expensive and
people would hate it but like it's like
the the idea though is like some white
lady with blue hair no offense and she
goes into like she reads a lot of
BuzzFeed and she goes into like a
Mexican food restaurant yeah and she
gets a peek while the door is swinging
and she's like oh good they're Mexican
cooks in there you know it's gonna be
the [ __ ] I'm like that's the most low IQ
and you never look at something we even
have that with like for example when we
first started doing a sip matcha right
yeah people would say let this isn't how
much it supposed to taste I was like
[ __ ] this comes from a [ __ ] old
Japanese [ __ ] I mailed this in us with
the stone from Japan yeah so how is this
not but you know they had that pre
notion that they think that they know
what it is because they had Starbucks
matcha yeah but this is about UCLA you
can't give up and take thank you exactly
so I mean like to that to that it's just
kind of like well why don't you just
talk to us first and then we could have
a conversation about it but instead you
would rather leave and just say your
[ __ ] so snobs
[Music]
you